The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: We're talking
about goodness-of-fit tests.
Goodness-of-fit tests
are, does my data
come from a particular
distribution?
And why would we
want to know this?
Well, maybe we're
interested in, for example,
knowing if the zodiac signs
of the Fortune 500 CEOs
are uniformly distributed.
Or maybe we actually
have slightly more--
slightly deeper endeavors,
such as understanding
if you can actually apply the
t-test by testing normality
of your sample.
All right?
So we saw that there's
the main result--
the main standard test for this.
It's called the
Kolmogorov-Smirnov test
that people use quite a bit.
It's probably one of the
most used tests out there.
And there's other versions of
it that I mentioned passing by.
There's the Cramer-von
Mises, and there's
the Anderson-Darling test.
Now, how would you
pick one of such tests?
Well, they're always are
going to-- they're always
going to have their
advantages and disadvantages.
And Kolmogorov-Smirnov is
definitely the most widely used
because--
well, I guess because
it's a natural notion
of distance between functions.
You just look for each
point how far they can be,
and you just look
at the farthest
they can be everywhere.
Now, Cramer-von Mises
involves L2 distance.
So if you're not used to
Hilbert spaces or notions
of Euclidean spaces, at least
it's a little more complicated.
And then Anderson-Darling
is definitely
even more complicated.
Now, each of these
tests is going
to be more powerful
against other alternatives.
So unless you can really
guess which alternative
you're expecting to
see, which you probably
don't, because, again, you're
in a case where you want
to typically declare H0
to be the correct one,
then it's really a
matter of tossing a coin.
Maybe you can run
all three of them
and just sleep better at night,
because all three of them
have failed to
reject, for example.
All right?
So as I mentioned, one of
the maybe primary goals
to test goodness of fit
is to be able to check
whether we can apply
Student's test, right,
and if the Student
distribution is actually
a valid distribution.
And for that, we need to have
normally distributed data.
Now, as I said several
times, normally distributed,
it's not a specific
distribution.
It's a family of
distributions that's
indexed by means and variances.
And the way I would want to test
if a distribution is normally
distributed is,
well, I would just
look at the most natural
normal distribution
or Gaussian distribution
that my data could follow.
That means that's the
Gaussian distribution that
has the same mean as my data
and the same empirical variance
as my data, right?
And so I'm going to be
given some points x1, xn,
and I'm going to be
asking, are those Gaussian?
That means this is
equivalent to, say,
are they N mu sigma square
for some mu sigma squared?
And of course,
the natural choice
is to take mu hat to be--
mu to be equal to mu
hat, which is xn bar.
And sigma squared to be
sigma squared hat to be,
well, Sn hat--
Sn-- what we wrote Sn, which
is 1/n sum from i equal 1 to n
of xi minus xn bar squared.
OK?
So this is definitely
the natural one
you would want to test.
And maybe you could actually
just close your eyes
and just stuff that in a
Kolmogorov-Smirnov test.
OK?
So here, there's a few
things that don't work.
The first one is that
Donsker's theorem does not
work anymore, right?
Donsker's theorem
was the one that
told us that,
properly normalized,
this thing would
actually converge
to the supremum of a Brownian
bridge, which is not true.
So that's one problem.
But there's actually
an even bigger problem
is that this distribution,
we will check in a second,
actually does not--
is pivotal itself, right,
the statistic is pivotal.
It does not have a
distribution that
depends on the known
parameters, which
is sort of nice, at
least under the null.
However, the distribution
is not the same
as the one that had
fixed mu and sigma.
The fact that they come
from some random variables
is actually distorting
the distribution itself.
And in particular, the quantiles
are going to be distorted,
and we hinted at that last time.
So one other thing I
need to tell you, though,
is that this thing actually--
so I know there's some--
oh, yeah, that's where
there's a word missing.
So we compute the quantiles
for this test statistic.
And so what I need
to promise to you
is that these
quantiles do not depend
on any unknown parameter, right?
I mean, it's not clear, right?
So I want to test whether
my data has some Gaussian
distribution.
So under the null, all I
know is that my xi's are
Gaussian with some mean mu
and some variance sigma,
which I don't know.
So it could be
the case that when
I try to understand the
distribution of this quantity
under the null, it depends on mu
and sigma, which I don't know.
So we need to check
that this is the case.
And what's actually
our redemption
here is actually going
to be the supremum.
The supremum is going
to basically allow
us to, say, sup out
mu and sigma square.
So let's check that, right?
So what I'm interested in
is this quantity, supremum
over t and R of the
difference between Fn of t
and, what I write, phi mu
hat sigma squared of t.
So phi mu hat
sigma hat squared--
sorry, sigma hat squared--
is the CDF of some Gaussian with
mean mu hat and variance sigma
hat squared.
And so in particular, this
thing here, phi hat of mu hat--
sorry, phi hat of mu hat
sigma hat squared of t
is the probability that
some x is less than t,
where x follows some N
mu hat sigma hat squared.
So what it means is that
by just the translation
and scaling trig
that we typically do
for Gaussian to turn it into
some standard Gaussian, that
implies that there
exists some z, which
is standard Gaussian this
time, so mean 0 and variance 1,
such that x is equal
to sigma hat x--
sorry, z plus mu hat.
Agreed?
That's basically saying that x
has some Gaussian with mean mu
and variance sigma squared.
And I'm not going to say the
hats every single time, OK?
So OK, so that's what it means.
So in particular, maybe
I shouldn't use x here,
because x is going
to be my actual data.
So let me write y.
OK?
So now what is this guy here?
It's basically-- so phi hat.
So this implies that phi mu
hat sigma hat squared of t
is equal to the probability
that sigma hat z
plus mu hat is
less than t, which
is equal to the probability
that z is less than t
minus mu hat divided
by sigma hat, right?
But now when z is
the standard normal,
this is really just the
cumulative distribution
function of a standard
Gaussian but evaluated
at a point which is
not t, but t minus mu
hat divided by sigma hat.
All right?
So in particular, what I know--
so from this what I get-- well,
maybe I'll remove that,
it's going to be annoying--
I know that phi mu hat
sigma hat squared--
sorry-- phi mu hat
sigma hat squared of t
is simply phi of, say, 0, 1.
And that's just the notation.
Usually we don't put those,
but here it's more convenient.
So it's phi 0, 1 of t minus
mu hat divided by sigma hat.
OK?
That's just something
you can quickly check.
There's this nice way of writing
the cumulative distribution
function for any
mean and any variance
in terms of the cumulative
distribution function
with mean 0 and variance 1.
All right?
Not too complicated.
All right.
So I know what I'm going to say
is that, OK, I have this sup
here.
So what I can write is
that this thing here
is equal to the sup
routine R of 1/n.
Let me write what Fn is--
sum from i equal 1
to n of the indicator
that xi is less than
t minus phi 0, 1
of t minus mu hat
divided by sigma hat.
OK?
I actually want to make
a change of variable
so that this thing
I'm going to call mu--
u, sorry.
OK?
And so I'm going to
make my life easier,
and I'm going to
make it appear here.
And so I'm just going to
replace this by indicator
that xi minus mu hat divided
by sigma hat less than t
minus mu hat divided
by sigma hat, which is
sort of useless at this point.
I'm just making my
formula more complicated.
But now I see something
here that shows up,
and I will call it u,
and this is another u.
OK?
So now what it means is that
suping over t, when t ranges
from negative infinity
to plus infinity,
the new range is from negative
infinity to plus infinity,
right?
So this sup, I can
actually write--
this suping t I can
write as the sup in u,
as the indicator that xi minus
mu hat divided by sigma hat
is less than u
minus phi 0, 1 of u.
Now, let's pause for one second.
Let's see where we're going.
What we're trying to show
that this thing does not
depend on the unknown
parameters, say, mu and sigma,
which are the mean and the
variance of x under the null.
To do that, we
basically need to make
only quantities that are sort
of invariant under these values.
So I tried to make this thing
invariant under anything,
and it's just really something
that depends on nothing.
It's the CDF.
It doesn't depend on sigma
hat and mu hat anymore.
But sigma hat and mu hat will
depend on mu and sigma, right?
I mean, they're actually good
estimators of those guys,
so they should be
pretty close to them.
And so I need to make
sure that I'm not actually
doing anything wrong here.
So the key thing here is going
to be to observe that 1/n sum
from i equal 1 to n of indicator
of xi minus u hat divided
by sigma hat less than u, which
is the first term that I have
in this absolute value,
well, this is what-- well,
this is equal to 1/n sum from
i equal 1 to n of indicator
that--
well, now under
the null, which is
that x follows N mu sigma
squared, for some mu and sigma
squared that are unknown.
But they are here.
They exist.
I just don't know what they are.
Then xi minus mu can be
written as sigma zi plus mu
minus mu hat divided
by sigma hat, where
z is equal to x minus mu
divided by sigma, right?
That's just the same
trick that I wrote here.
OK?
Everybody agree?
So I just standardize--
sorry, z-- yeah, so zi is xi
minus mu i minus mu divided
by sigma.
All right?
Just a standardization.
So now once I write
this, I can actually
divide everybody by sigma.
Right?
So I just divided on top
here and in the bottom here.
So now what I need to check
is that the distribution
of this guy does not
depend on mu or sigma.
That's what I claim.
What is the distribution
of this indicator?
It's a Bernoulli, right?
And so if I want to
understand its distribution,
all I need to do is to
compute its expectation,
which is just the probability
that this thing happens.
But the probability
that this thing happens
is actually now depending
on mu and sigma.
And the reason is
that mu is what?
Well, it's x bar-- sorry, yeah,
so mu hat-- sorry, is xn bar.
So mu hat minus mu,
which under the null
follows N mu sigma
square over n, right?
That's the property
of the average.
So when I do mu hat minus
mu divided by sigma,
this thing is what distribution?
It's still a normal.
It's a linear
transformation of a normal.
What are the parameters?
AUDIENCE: 0, 1/n.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah, 0, 1/n.
But this does not depend
on mu or sigma, right?
Now, I need to check
that this guy does not
depend on mu or sigma.
What is the distribution
of sigma hat over sigma?
AUDIENCE: It's a
chi-square, right?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah,
it is a chi-square.
So this is actually--
sorry, sigma hat squared
divided by sigma squared
is a chi-square with n
minus 1 degrees of freedom.
Does not depend on mu or sigma.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Or sigma hat
squared over sigma squared?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Yeah, thank you.
So this is actually
divided by it.
So maybe this guy.
Let's write it like that.
This is the proper
way of writing it.
Thank you.
Right?
So now I have those two things.
Neither of them
depends on mu or sigma.
I these two things.
There's just one
more thing to check.
What is it?
AUDIENCE: That
they're independent?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: That
they're independent, right?
Because the dependence
in mu and sigma
could be hidden
in the covariance.
It could be the case that the
marginal distribution of mu
does not depend on mu or sigma,
that the marginal distribution
of sigma--
of mu hat does not
depend on mu and sigma.
The marginal
distribution of sigma hat
does not depend on mu or
sigma, but their correlation
could depend on mu and sigma.
But we also have
that if I look at--
so if I look at--
so since mu hat is
independent of sigma hat,
it means that the joint
distribution of mu hat divided
by sigma and sigma
hat divided by sigma
does not depend on blah,
blah, blah, on mu and sigma.
OK?
Agree?
It's not in the individual
ones, and it's not
in the way they interact
with each other.
It's nowhere.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
independence be [INAUDIBLE]
theorem?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah,
covariance theorem, right.
So that's something we've
been using over and again.
That's all under the null.
If my data is not Gaussian,
nothing actually holds.
I just use the fact
that under the null
I'm Gaussian for some mean mu
and variance sigma squared.
But that's all I care about.
When I'm designing
a test, I only
care about the distribution
under the null, at least
to control the type I error.
Then to control
the type II error,
then I cross my
fingers pretty hard.
OK?
So now this basically implies
what's written on the board,
that this distribution,
this test statistic,
does not depend on any
unknown parameters.
It's just something
that's pivotal.
In particular, I could
go at the back of a book
and check if there's a table for
the quantiles of these things,
and indeed there are.
This is the table that you see.
So actually, this is
not even in a book.
This is in Lilliefors
original paper, 1967,
as you can tell from
the typewriting.
And he actually probably
was rolling some dice
from his office back in
the day and was checking
that this was-- he
simulated it, and this is
how he computed those numbers.
And here you also have
some limiting distribution,
which is not the sup of
a Brownian motion over 0,
1 of-- sorry, of a
Brownian bridge over 0,
1, which is the
one that you would
see for the
Kolmogorov-Smirnov test,
but it's something that's
slightly different.
And as I said, these numbers are
actually typically much smaller
than the numbers you
would get, right?
Remember, we got something
that was about 0.5, I think,
or maybe 0.41, for the
Kolmogorov-Smirnov test
at the same
entrance, which means
that using
Kolmogorov-Lilliefors test
it's going to be
harder for you not
to reject for the same data.
It might be the case that
in one case you reject,
and in the other one
you fail to reject.
But the ordering is
always that if you
fail to reject with
Kolmogorov-Lilliefors,
you will fail to reject with
Kolmogorov-Smirnov, right?
There's always one.
So that's why people
tend to close their eyes
and prefer Kolmogorov-Smirnov
because it just
makes their life easier.
OK?
So this is called
Kolmogorov-Lilliefors.
I think there's
actually an E here--
sorry, an I before the E.
Doesn't matter too much.
OK?
Are there any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there
like a place you
can point to like [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So the
fact that it's actually
a different distribution
is that here--
so if I actually knew
what mu and sigma were,
I would do exactly
the same thing.
But here, rather than having
this average with mu and sigma,
I would just have the--
with mu hat and sigma
hat, I would just
have the average
with mu and sigma.
OK?
So what it means is
that the key thing
is that what I would compare is
the 1/n sum of some Bernoullis
with parameter.
And the parameter here would
be the probability that mu--
xi minus mu over
sigma is less than u,
which is just the
probability that phi--
sorry, it's a Bernoulli
with probability F of t.
Well, let me write
what it is, right?
So that's minus phi 0, 1 of t.
OK?
So that's for the K-S test,
and then I sup over t, right?
That's what I would have
had, because this is actually
exactly the right thing.
Here I would remove
the true mean.
I would divide by the
true standard deviation.
So that would actually end
up being a standard Gaussian,
and that's why I'm allowed
to use phi 0, 1 here.
Agreed?
And these are Bernoullis
because they're just indicators.
What happens in the
Kolmogorov-Lilliefors test?
Well, here the
Bernoulli, the only thing
that's going to change
is this guy, right?
They still have a Bernoulli.
It's just that the parameters
of the Bernoulli are weird.
The parameters of the
Bernoulli looks like it's--
it becomes the probability that
some N(0, 1) plus some N(0,
1/n), right, divided by some
square root of chi-squared n
minus 1 divided by
n is less than t.
And those things
are independent,
but those guys are not
necessarily independent, right?
And so why is this
probability changing?
Well, because this denominator
is actually fluctuating a lot.
So that actually makes
this probability different.
And so that's basically
where it comes from, right?
So you could probably
convince yourself
very quickly that this only
makes those guys closer.
And why does it make
those guys closer?
No, sorry.
It makes those guys
farther, right?
And it makes those guys farther
for a very clear reason,
is that the expectation of this
Bernoulli is exactly that guy.
Here I think it's
going to be true
as well that the expectation
of this Bernoulli
is going to be that guy,
but the fluctuations
are going to be much bigger than
just the phi of the Bernoulli.
Because the first
thing I do is I
have a random parameter
from my Bernoulli,
and then I flip the Bernoulli.
So fluctuations are going to
be bigger than a Bernoulli.
And so when I take
the sup, I'm going
to have to [INAUDIBLE] them.
So it makes things
farther apart,
which makes it more
likely for you to reject.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You also said that if
you compare the same-- if you
compare the table and you
set at the same level,
the Lilliefors is like 0.2,
and for the Smirnov is at 0.4.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So it means that Lilliefors
is harder not to reject?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: It means
that Lilliefors is harder
not to reject, yes,
because we reject when
we're larger than the number.
So the number being smaller
with the same data, we might be,
right?
So basically, it
looks like this.
What we run-- so here we have
the distribution for the--
so let's say this is
the density for K-S.
And then we have the density for
Kolmogorov-Lilliefors, K-L. OK?
And what the density
of K-L looks like,
it looks like this, right?
And so if I want to
squeeze in alpha here,
I'm going to have to squeeze
in-- and I squeeze in alpha
here, then this is the
quantile of order 1 minus alp--
well, let's say
alpha of the K-L.
And this is the
quantile alpha of K-S.
So now you give me data,
and what I do with it,
I check whether they're
larger than this number.
So if I apply K-S, I check
whether I'm larger or smaller
than this thing.
But if I apply
Kolmogorov-Lilliefors,
I check whether I'm larger
or smaller than this thing.
So over this entire range of
values for my test statistic--
because it is the
same test statistic,
I just plugged in mu
hat and sigma hat--
for this entire range, the two
tests have different outcomes.
And this is a big range
in practice, right?
I mean, it's between--
I mean, it's pretty
much at scale here.
OK?
Any other-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] when n
goes to infinity, the two tests
become the same now, right?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Hmmm.
AUDIENCE: Looking
at that formula--
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah,
They should become the same
very far.
Let me see, though, because--
right.
So here we have 8--
so here we have, say,
for 0.5, we get 0.886.
And for-- oh, I don't have it.
Yeah, actually, sorry.
So you're right.
You're totally right.
This is the Brownian
bridge values.
Because in the limit
by, say, Slutsky--
sorry, I'm lost.
Yeah, these are
the values that you
get for the Brownian bridge.
Because in the limit
by Slutsky, this thing
is going to have no
fluctuation, and this thing
is going to have no fluctuation.
So they're just going
to be pinned down,
and it's going to look like as
if I did not replace anything.
Because in the limit, I know
those guys much faster--
the mu hat and
sigma hat converge
much faster to mu and sigma than
the distribution itself, right?
So those are actually
going to be negligible.
You're right.
Actually even, I didn't have--
these are actually the
numbers I showed you
for the bridge, the
Brownian bridge,
last time, because I didn't have
it for the Kolmogorov-Smirnov
one.
OK?
So there's actually-- so those
are numerical ways of checking
things, right?
I give you data.
You just crank the
Kolmogorov-Smirnov test.
Usually you press a 5 on MATLAB.
But let's say you actually
compute this entire thing,
and there's a number
that comes out,
and you decide whether it's
large enough or small enough.
Of course, statistical software
is going to make your life even
simpler by spitting out a
p-value, because you can--
I mean, if you can compute
quantiles, you can also
when compute p-values.
And so your life is
just fairly easy.
You just have red is bad, green
is good, and then you can go.
The problem is that those are
numbers you want to rely on.
But let's say you
actually reject.
Let's say you reject.
Your p-value is actually
just like slightly below 5%.
So you can say, well, maybe
I'm just going to change
my p-value--
my threshold to
1%, but you might
want to see what's happening.
And for that you need
a visual diagnostic.
Like, how do I check
if something departs
from being normal, for example?
How do I check if
a distribution--
why is a distribution not
a uniform distribution?
Why is a distribution not
an exponential distribution?
There's many, many, right?
If I have an
exponential distribution
and half of my
values are negative,
for example, well, there's
like pretty obvious reasons
why it should not
be exponential.
But it could be
the case that it's
just the tails
are little heavier
or there's more
concentration at some point.
Maybe it has two modes.
There's things like this.
But the real thing,
we don't believe
that the Gaussian is
so important because it
looks like this close to 0.
What we like about the
Gaussian is that the tails here
decay at this rate--
exponential minus x
squared over 2 that we described
in the maybe first lecture.
And in particular, if there
were like kinks around here,
it wouldn't matter too much.
This is not what makes
issues for the Gaussian.
And so what we want is to have a
visual diagnostic that tells us
if the tails of my
distribution are
comparable to the tails of
a Gaussian one, for example.
And those are what's called
quantile-quantile plots,
and in particular-- or QQ plots.
And the basic QQ plots
we're going to be using
are the ones that are
called normal QQ plots that
are comparing your data to
a Gaussian distribution,
or a normal distribution.
But in general, you could
be comparing your data
to any distribution you want.
And the way you do
this is by comparing
the quantiles of your data,
the empirical quantiles,
to the quantiles of
the actual distribution
you're trying to
compare yourself to.
So this, in a way,
is a visual way
of performing these
goodness-of-fit tests.
And what's nice about visual is
that there's room for debate.
You can see something that
somebody else cannot see,
and you can always-- because
you want to say that things are
Gaussian.
And we'll see some examples
where you can actually say it
if you are good at
debate, but it's actually
going to be clearly not true.
All right.
So this is a quick
and easy check.
That's something
I do all the time.
You give me data, I'm
just going to run this.
One of the first
things I do so I
can check if I can start
entering the Gaussian
world without compromising
myself too much.
And the idea is to say, well,
if F is close to-- if F--
if my data comes
from an F, and if I
know that Fn is close
to F, then rather
than computing some norm,
some number that tells me
how far they are,
summarizing how far they are,
I could actually plot
the two functions
and see if they're far apart.
So let's think for one second
what this kind of a plot
would look like.
Well, I would go
between 0 and 1.
That's where everything
would happen.
Let's say my distribution is
the Gaussian distribution.
So this is the CDF of N(0, 1).
And now I have this guy
that shows up, and remember
we had this piecewise constant.
Well, OK, let's say we
get something like this.
We get a piecewise constant
distribution for Fn, right?
Just from this, and even despite
my bad skills at drawing,
it's clear that it's
going to be hard
for you to distinguish
those two things,
even for a fairly
large amount of points.
Because the problem is
going to happen here,
and those guys look pretty
much the same everywhere
you are here.
You're going to see differences
maybe in the middle,
but we don't care too much
about those differences.
And so what's going to
happen is that you're
going to want to compare
those two things.
And this is basically you
have the information you want,
but visually it just doesn't
render very well because you're
not scaling things properly.
And the way we actually do it
is by flipping things around.
And rather than comparing the
plot of F to the plot of Fn,
we compare the
plot of Fn inverse
to the plot of F inverse.
Now, if F goes from the real
line to the interval 0, 1,
F inverse goes from 0, 1
to the whole real line.
So what's going to
happen is that I'm
going to compare things on
some intervals, which is the--
which are the entire real line.
And then what values should I
be looking at those things at?
Well, technically for
F, if F is continuous I
could look at F inverse for
any value that I please, right?
So I have F. And if I
want to look at F inverse,
I pick a point here and I look
at the value that it gives me,
and that's F inverse of,
say, u, right, if this is u.
And I could pick
any value I want,
I'm going to be able to find it.
The problem is that
when I start to have
this piecewise
constant thing, I need
to decide what value I
assign for anything that's
in between two jumps, right?
And so I can choose
whatever I want,
but in practice it's
just going to be things
that I myself decide.
Maybe I can decide
that this is the value.
that the value is here.
But for all these guys, I'm
going to pretty much decide
always the same value, right?
If I'm in between--
for this value u, for this
jump the jump is here.
So for this value,
I'm going to be
able to decide whether I
want to go above or below,
but it's always this value
that's going to come out.
So rather than picking
values that are in between,
I might as well just
pick only values
for which this is the value
that it's going to get.
And those values are
exactly 1/n, 2/n, 3/n, 4/n.
It's all the way to n/n, right?
That's exactly where
the flat parts are.
We know we jump
from 1/n every time.
And so that's
exactly the recipe.
It says look at those
values, 1/n, 2/n, 3/n
until, say, n minus 1 over n.
And for those values,
compute the inverse
of both the empiricial
CDF and the true CDF.
Now, for the empirical
CDF, it's actually easy.
I just told you this is
basically where the points--
where the jumps occur.
And the jumps occur where?
Well, exactly at
my observations.
Now, remember I need to sort
those observations to talk
about them.
So the one that occurs
for the i-th jump
is the i-th largest observation,
which we denoted by X sub (i).
Remember?
We had this formula that we
said, well, we have x1, xn.
These are my data.
And what I'm going
to sort them into
is x sub (1), which is
less than or equal to x
sub (2), which is
less than x sub (n).
OK?
So we just ordered them
from smallest to largest.
And then now we've
done that, we just
put this parenthesis notation.
So in particular,
Fn inverse of i/n
is the location where
the i-th jumps occur,
which is the i-th
largest observation.
OK?
So for this guy, these
values, the y-axes
are actually fairly easy.
I know it's basically
my ordered observations.
The x-values are-- well,
that depends on the function
F I'm trying to test.
If it's the Gaussian,
it's just the quantile
of order 1 minus 1/n, right?
It's this Q1 minus 1/n here
that I need to compute.
It's the inverse of the
cumulative distribution
function, which, given
the formula for F,
you can actually compute or
maybe estimate fairly well.
But it's something that
you can find in tables.
Those are basically quantiles.
Inverse of CDFs are
quantiles, right?
And so that's basically the
things we're interested in.
That's why it's called
quantile-quantile.
Those are sometimes referred
to as theoretical quantiles,
the one we're trying to test,
and empirical quantiles,
the one that corresponds
to the empirical CDF.
And so I'm plotting a plot
where the x-axis is quantile.
The y-axis is quantile.
And so I call this plot a
quantile-quantile plot, or QQ
plot, because, well, just say
10 times quantile-quantile,
and then you'll see why.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] have
to have the [INAUDIBLE]??
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Well, that's just--
we're back to the--
we're back to the
goodness-of-fit test, right?
So if you look--
so you don't do it yourself.
That's the simple answer.
You don't-- I'm just telling you
how those plots are going to be
seen spit out from a software
are going to look like.
Now, depending on
the software, there's
a different thing
that's happening.
Some softwares are actually
plotting F with the right--
let's say you want to
do normal, as you asked.
So some software are
just going to use F
to be with mu hat and
sigma hat, and that's fine.
Some software are actually
not going to do this.
They're just going
to use a Gaussian.
But then they're
going to actually have
a different reference point.
So what do we want to see here?
What should happen
if all these points--
if all my points
actually come from F,
from a distribution
that has CDF F?
What should happen?
What should I see?
Well, since Fn
should be close to F,
Fn inverse should be
close to F inverse, which
means that this point should
be close to that point.
This point should be
close to that point.
So ideally, if I actually
pick the right F,
I should see a plot that looks
like this, something where
all my points are very
close to the line y
is equal to x, right?
And I'm going to have
some fluctuations,
but something very
close to this.
Now, that's if F is
exactly the right one.
If F is not exactly the
right one, in particular,
in the case of a Gaussian
one, if I actually
plotted here the quantiles--
so if I plotted F
0, 1 of t, right?
So let's say those are
the ones I actually plot,
but I really don't know
what-- mu hat is not 0
and sigma hat is not 0.
And so this is not the
one I should be getting.
Since we actually know that
phi of mu hat sigma hat
squared t is equal to phi 0,
1 of t minus mu hat divided
by sigma hat, there's
just this change
of axis, which is
actually very simple.
This change of axis is just
a simple translation scaling,
which means that
this line here is
going to be transformed
into another line
with a different slope
and a different intercept.
And so some software
will actually decide
to go with this curve
and just show you
what the reference
curve should be,
rather than actually
putting everything back
onto the 45-degree curve.
AUDIENCE: So if you
get any straight line?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Any
straight line, you're happy.
I mean, depending
on the software.
Because if the software actually
really rescaled this thing
to have mu hat and sigma square
and you find a different line,
a different straight
line, this is
bad news, which is not
going to happen actually.
It's impossible that happens,
because you actually-- well,
it could.
If it's crazy, it could.
It shouldn't be very crazy.
OK.
So let's see what R does
for us, for example.
So here in R, R actually
does this funny trick where--
so here I did not
actually plot the lines.
I should actually add the lines.
So the command is like
qqnorm of my sample, right?
And that's really simple.
I just stack all my data
into some vector, say, x.
And I say qqnorm of x, and
it just spits this thing out.
OK?
Very simple.
But I could actually
add another command,
which I can't remember.
I think it's like qqline,
and it's just going
to add the line on top of it.
But if you see, actually
what R does for us,
it's actually doing the
translation and scaling
on the axes themselves.
So it actually changes
the x and y-axis in such a
way that when you
look at your picture
and you forget about what
the meaning of the axes are,
the relevant straight
line is actually
still the 45-degree line.
It's Because it's actually done
the change of units for you.
So you don't have to
even see the line.
You know that, in your mind,
that this is basically--
the reference line is still
45 degree because that's
the way the axes are made.
But if I actually put my axes,
right-- so here, for example,
it goes from--
let's look at some--
well, OK, those are all square.
Yeah, and that's probably
because they actually have--
the samples are actually
from a standard normal.
So I did not make
my life very easy
to illustrate your
question, but of course, I
didn't know you were
going to ask it.
Next time, let's just prepare.
Let's script more.
We'll see another
one in the next plot.
But so here what
you expect to see
is that all the plots should be
on the 45-degree line, right?
This should be the right one.
And if you see, when I
start having 10,000 samples,
this is exactly
what's happening.
So this is as good as it gets.
This is an N(0, 1) plotted
against the theoretical
quantile of an N(0, 1).
As good as it gets.
And if you see, for the
second one, which is 50,
sample size of size--
sample of size 50, there is
some fudge factor, right?
I mean, those things--
doesn't look like there's
a straight line, right?
It sort of appears that there
are some weird things happening
here at the lower tail.
And the reason why
this is happening
is because we're trying to
compare the tails, right?
When I look at this picture,
the only thing that goes wrong
somehow is always at
the tip, because those
are sort of rare
and extreme values,
and they're sort of
all over the place.
And so things are never really
super smooth and super clean.
So this is what
your best shot is.
This is what you will
ever hope to get.
So size 10, right, so
you have 10 points.
Remember, we actually--
well, I didn't really
tell you how to deal
with the extreme cases.
Because the problem is that
F inverse of 1 for the true F
is plus infinity.
So you have to make some sort
of weird boundary choices
to decide what F inverse
of 1 is, and it's something
that's like somewhere.
But you still want to
put like 10 dots, right?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10 dots.
So I have 10 observations,
you will see 10 dots.
I have 50 observations, you
will see 50 dots, right,
because I have--
there are 1/n, 2/n,
3/n all the way to n/n.
I didn't tell you the last one.
OK.
So this is when things
go well, and this is
when things should not go well.
OK?
So here, actually,
the distribution
is a Student's t with
15 degrees of freedom,
which should depart somewhat
from a Gaussian distribution.
The tails should be heavier.
And what you can see is
basically the following,
is that for 10 you actually see
something that's crazy, right,
if I do 10 observations.
But if I do 50
observations, honestly, it's
kind of hard to say
that it's different
from the standard normal.
So you could still be
happy with this for 100.
And then this is what's
happening for 10,000.
And even here it's not the
beautiful straight line,
but it feels like you
would be still tempted
to conclude that it's a
beautiful straight line.
So let's try to guess.
So basically, there's-- for
each of those sides there's two
phenomena.
Either it goes like this
or it goes like this,
and then it goes like
this or it goes like this.
Each side corresponds to the
left tail, all the smallest
values.
So that's the left side.
And that's the right
side-- corresponds
to the large values.
OK?
And so basically
you can actually
think of some sort of
a table that tells you
what your QQ plot looks like.
And so let's say it looks--
so we have our reference
45-degree line.
So let's say this
is the QQ plot.
That could be one thing.
This could be the QQ plot
where I have another thing.
Then I can do this guy,
and then I do this guy.
So this is like this.
OK?
So those are the four cases.
And here what's changing
is the right tail,
and here what's
changing is the--
and when I go from here to here,
what changes is the left tail.
Is that true?
No, sorry.
What changes here is
the right tail, right?
It's this part that
changes from top to bottom.
So here it's something
about right tail,
and here that's something
about left tail.
Everybody understands what I
mean when I talk about tails?
OK.
And so here it's
just going to be
a question of whether
the tails are heavier
or lighter than the Gaussian.
Everybody understand
what I mean when I say
heavy tails and light tails?
OK.
So right, so heavy
tails just means
that basically here
the tails of this guy
are heavier than the
tails of this guy.
So it means that if I draw
them, they're going to be above.
Actually, I'm going to keep
this picture because it's
going to be very useful for me.
When I plug the quantiles
at the same-- so let's
look at the right
tail, for example.
Right here my picture
is for right tails.
When I look at the quantiles of
my theoretical distribution--
so here you can see
the bottom curve
we have the
theoretical quantiles,
and those are the
empirical quantiles.
If I look to the right here,
are the theoretical quantiles
larger or smaller than
the empirical quantiles?
Let me phrase it the other--
are the empirical
quantiles larger or smaller
than the theoretical quantiles?
AUDIENCE: This is a graph
of quantiles, right?
So if it's [INAUDIBLE]
it should be smaller.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: It
should be smaller, right?
On this line, they are equal.
So if I see the empirical
quantile showing up here,
it means that here the
empirical quantile is less
than the theoretical quantile.
Agree?
So that means that if
I look at this thing--
and that's for the
same values, right?
So the quantiles are computed
for the same values i/n.
So it means that the empirical
quantiles should be looking--
so that should be the
empirical quantile,
and that should be the
theoretical quantile.
Agreed?
Those are the smaller
values for the same alpha.
So that implies that the tails--
the right tail, is
it heavy or lighter--
heavier or lighter
than the Gaussian?
AUDIENCE: Lighter.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Lighter, right?
Because those are the
tails of the Gaussian.
Those are my
theoretical quantiles.
That means that this is the tail
of my empirical distribution.
So they are actually lighter.
OK?
So here, if I look
at this thing,
this means that the right
tail is actually light.
And by light, I mean
lighter than Gaussian.
Heavy, I mean heavier
than Gaussian.
OK?
OK, now we can probably
do the entire thing.
Well, if this is light, this
is going to be heavy, right?
That's when I'm above the curve.
Exercise-- is this light or is
this heavy, the first column?
And it's OK.
It should take you
at least 30 seconds.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
different column?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah,
this column, right?
So this is something
that pertains--
this entire column is going
to tell me whether the fact
that this guy is
above, does this
mean that I have lighter
or heavier left tails?
AUDIENCE: Well, on the
left, it's heavier.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: On
the left, it's heavier.
OK.
I don't know.
Actually, I need
to draw a picture.
You guys are probably
faster than I am.
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES].
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Actually, let me
check how much randomness is--
who says it's lighter?
Who says it's heavier?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
but we're biased.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah, OK.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: All right.
So let's see if it's heavier.
So we're on the left tail, and
so we have one looks like this,
one looks like that, right?
So we know here that I'm
looking at this part here.
So it means that here my
empirical quantile is larger
than the theoretical quantile.
OK?
So are my tails
heavier or lighter?
They're lighter.
That was a bad bias.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Right?
It's below, so it's lighter.
Because the problem is that
larger for the negative ones
means that it's smaller
[INAUDIBLE],, right?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Sorry but, what
exactly are these [INAUDIBLE]??
If this is the inverse--
if this is the inverse
CDF, shouldn't everything--
well, if this is
the inverse CDF,
then you should
only be inputting
values between 0 and 1 in it.
And--
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Oh,
did I put the inverse CDF?
AUDIENCE: Like on the
previous slide, I think.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
No, the inverse
CDF, yeah, so I'm inputting--
AUDIENCE: Oh,
you're [INAUDIBLE]..
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah, so
it's a scatter plot, right?
So each point is
attached-- each point
is attached 1/n, 2/n, 3/n.
Now, for each
point I'm plotting,
that's my x-value, which
maps a number between 0 and 1
back onto the entire real line,
and my y-value is the same.
OK?
So what it means is that those
two numbers, this is in the--
this lives on the entire real
line, not on the interval.
This lives on the entire real
line, not in the interval.
And so my QQ plots take values
on the entire real line,
entire real line, right?
So you think of it as a
parameterized curve, where
the time steps
are 1/n, 2/n, 3/n,
and I'm just like putting a dot
every time I'm making one step.
OK?
OK, so what did we say?
That was lighter, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: OK?
One of my favorite exercises
is, here's a bunch of densities.
Here's a bunch of QQ plots.
Map the correct QQ plot
to its own density.
All right?
And there won't be mingled
lines that allow you to do that,
then you just have to follow,
like at the back of cereal
boxes.
All right.
Are there any questions?
So one thing--
there's two things
I'm trying to
communicate here is
if you see a QQ plot, now
you should understand,
one, how it was built, and two,
whether it means that you have
heavier tails or lighter tails.
Now, let's look at this guy.
What should we see?
We should see heavy on the left
and heavy on the right, right?
We know that this
should be the case.
So this thing actually looks
like this, and it sort of does,
right?
If I take this line
going through here,
I can see that this
guy's tipping here,
and this guy's dipping here.
But honestly-- actually, I can't
remember exactly, but t 15,
if I plotted the density
on top of the Gaussian,
you can see a difference.
But if I just gave it to
you, it would be very hard
for you to tell me if there's
an actual difference between t
15 and Gaussian, right?
Those things are
actually very close.
And so in particular,
here we're really
trying to recognize what
the shape is the fact--
right?
So t 15 compared to a standard
Gaussian was different,
but t 15 compared to a Gaussian
with a slightly larger variance
is not going to actually--
you're not going
to see much of a difference.
So in a way, such
distributions are actually not
too far from the Gaussian,
and it's not too--
it's still pretty benign to
conclude that this was actually
a Gaussian distribution because
you can just use the variance
as a little bit of a buffer.
I'm not going to
get really into how
you would use a
t-distribution into a t-test,
because it's kind of
like Inception, right?
So but you could pretend
that your data actually
is t-distributed and then
build a t-distribution from it,
but let's not say that.
Maybe that was a bad example.
But there's like other
heavy-tailed distributions like
Cauchy distribution, which
doesn't even have a--
it's not even integrable
because that's
as heavy as the tails get.
And this you can really tell
it's going to look like this.
It's going to be like pfft.
What does a uniform
distribution look like?
Like this?
It's going to be-- it's going
to look like a Gaussian one,
right?
So a uniform-- so
this is my Gaussian.
A uniform is basically
going to look like this,
one side take the right mean
and the right variance, right?
So the tails are
definitely lighter.
They're 0.
That's as lighter as it gets.
So the light-light is going
to look like this S shape.
So an S-- light-tailed
distribution has this S shape.
OK?
What is the exponential
going to look like?
So the exponential is
positively supported.
It only has positive numbers.
So there's no left tail.
This is also as
light as it gets.
But the right tail, is
it heavier or lighter
than the Gaussian?
AUDIENCE: Heavier.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
It's heavier, right?
It's only the case like e of the
minus x rather e to the minus
x squared.
So it's heavier.
So it means that on the
left it's going to be light,
and on the right it's
going to be heavy.
So it's going to be U-shaped.
OK?
That will be fine.
All right.
Any other question?
Again, two messages,
like, more technical,
and you can sort of fiddle
with it by looking at it.
You can definitely
conclude that this
is OK enough to be
Gaussian for your purposes.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: I
did not hear the "if"
at the beginning
of your sentence.
AUDIENCE: I would want to
be lighter tail, right,
because that'll be--
it's easier to reject?
Is that correct?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So what
is your purpose as a--
AUDIENCE: I want to--
I have some [INAUDIBLE] right?
I want to be able to say
I reject H0 [INAUDIBLE]..
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So if you
wanted to make it easier
to reject H0, then--
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah, in
a way that's true, right?
So once you've actually factored
in the mean and the variance,
the only thing that actually--
right.
So if you have Gaussian tails
or lighter-- even lighter tails,
then it's harder for you
to explain deviations
from randomness only, right?
If you have a
uniform distribution
and you see something which is--
if you're uniform on 0, 1 plus
some number and you see 25,
you know this number is
not going to be 0, right?
So that's basically
as good as it gets.
And there's basically
some smooth interpolation
if you have lighter tails.
Now, if you start having
something that has heavy tails,
then it's more likely
that pure noise
will generate large observations
and therefore discovery.
So yes, lighter
tails is definitely
the better-behaved noise.
Let's put it this way.
The lighter it is, the
better behaved it is.
Now, this is good--
this is good for some purposes,
but when you want to compute
actual quantiles,
like exact quantiles,
then it is true in general that
the quantiles of lighter-tail
distributions are going to be
dominated by the-- are going
to be dominated by the--
let's say on the
right tails, are
going to be dominated by
those of a heavy distribution.
That is true.
But that's not always the case.
And in particular,
there's going to be
some like sort of weird points
where things are actually
changing depending on what
level you're actually looking
at those things,
maybe 5% or 10%,
in which case things might
be changing a little bit.
But if you started going
really towards the tail,
if you start looking at levels
alpha which are 1% or 0.1%,
it is true that it's always--
if you can actually--
so if you see something
that looks light
tail, you definitely
do not want to conclude
that it's Gaussian.
You want to actually change
your modeling so that it
makes your life even easier.
And you actually
factor in the fact
that you can see that the
noise is actually more benign
than you would like it to be.
OK?
Stretching fingers, that's it?
All right.
OK.
So I want to--
I mentioned at some point that
we had this chi-square test
that was showing up.
And I do not know what I did--
let's just-- oh, yeah.
So we have this chi-square test
that we worked on last time,
right?
So the way I introduced the
chi-square test is by saying,
I am fascinated
by this question.
Let's check if it's correct, OK?
Or something maybe
slightly deeper--
let's check if juries
in this country
are representative of
racial distribution.
But you could actually--
those numbers here
come from a very specific thing.
That was the uniform.
That was our benchmark.
Here's the uniform.
And there was this guy,
which was a benchmark, which
was the actual benchmark that we
need to have for this problem.
And those things basically
came out of my hat, right?
Those are numbers that exist.
But in practice, you actually
make those numbers yourself.
And the way you do it
is by saying, well,
if I have a binomial
distribution
and I want to test
if my data comes
from a binomial
distribution, you
could ask this question, right?
You have a bunch of data.
I did not promise
to you that this
was the sum of independent
Bernoullis and [INAUDIBLE]..
And then you can actually check
that it's a binomial indeed,
and you have binomial.
If you think about where
you've encountered binomials,
it was mostly when
you were drawing balls
from urns, which you probably
don't do that much in practice.
OK?
And so maybe one day you want
to model things as a binomial,
or maybe you want to
model it as a Poisson,
as a limiting binomial, right?
People tell you photons arrive--
the rate of a photon
hitting some surface
is actually a Poisson
distribution, right?
That's where they
arise a lot in imaging.
So if I have a colleague
who's taking pictures
of the skies over night, and
he's like following stars
and it's just like moving around
with the rotation of the Earth.
And he has to do this
for like eight hours
because he needs to get enough
photons over this picture
to actually arise.
And he knows they arrive
at like a Poisson process,
and you know, chapter 7 of your
probability class, I guess.
And
And there's all
these distributions
outside the classroom
you probably
want to check that
they're actually correct.
And so the first one you might
want to check, for example,
is a binomial.
So I give you a distribution,
a binomial distribution
on, say, K trials, and
you have some number p.
And here, I don't know
typically what p should be,
but let's say I know it or
estimate it from my data.
And here, since we're only
going to deal with asymptotics,
just like it was the case for
the Kolmogorov-Smirnov one,
in the asymptotic
we're going to be
able to think of the estimated
p as being a true p, OK,
under the null at least.
So therefore, each outcome,
I can actually tell you what
the probability of a binomial--
is this outcome.
For a given K and a
given p, I can tell you
exactly what a binomial
should give you
as the probability
for the outcome.
And that's what I actually use
to replace the numbers 1/12,
1/12, 1/12, 1/12 or the
numbers 0.72, 0.7, 0.12, 0.9.
All these numbers I
can actually compute
using the probabilities
of a binomial, right?
So I know, for example, that the
probability that a binomial np
is equal to, say, K is n
choose K p to the K 1 minus p
to the n minus K. OK?
I mean, so these are numbers.
If you give me p
and you give me n,
I can compute those numbers
for all K from 0 to n.
And from this I can
actually build a table.
All right?
So for each K--
0.
So K is here, and
from 0, 1, et cetera,
all the way to n, I can compute
the true probability, which
is the probability that my
binomial np is equal to 0,
the probability that my binomial
is equal to 1, et cetera,
all the way to n.
I can compute those numbers.
Those are actually going
to be exact numbers, right?
I just plug in the
formula that I had.
And then I'm going to
have some observed.
So that's going to be p
hat, 0, and that's basically
the proportion of 0's, right?
So here you have to remember
it's not a one-time experiment
like you do in
probability where you say,
I'm going to draw n
balls from an urn,
and I'm counting how many--
how many I have.
This is statistics.
I need to be able to do
this experiment many times
so I can actually, in the
end, get an idea of what
the proportion of p's is.
So you have not
just one binomial,
but you have n binomials.
Well, maybe I should
not use n twice.
So that's why it's
the K here, right?
So I have a binomial
[INAUDIBLE] at Kp
and I just seize
n of those guys.
And with this n of those
guys, I can actually
estimate those probabilities.
And what I'm going
to want to check
is if those two
probabilities are actually
close to each other.
But I already know
how to do this.
All right?
So here I'm going
to test whether P
is in some parametric
family, for example,
binomial or not binomial.
And testing-- if I know that
it's a binomial [INAUDIBLE],,
and I basically just have to
test if P is the right thing.
OK?
Oh, sorry, I'm actually
lying to you here.
OK.
I don't want to test
if it's binomial.
I want to test the parameter
of the binomial here.
OK?
So I know-- no, sorry,
[INAUDIBLE] sorry.
OK.
So I want to know if
I'm in some family,
the family of binomials, or
not in the family of binomials.
OK?
Well, that's what I want to do.
And so here H0 is basically
equivalent to testing
if the pj's are the pj's
that come from the binomial.
And the pj's here are the
probabilities that I get.
This is the probability
that I get j successes.
That's my pj.
That's j's value here.
OK?
So this is the example,
and we know how to do this.
We construct p hat,
which is the estimated
proportion of successes
from the observations.
So here now I have n trials.
This is the actual maximum
likelihood estimator.
This becomes a multinomial
experiment, right?
So it's kind of confusing.
We have a multinomial experiment
for a binomial distribution.
The binomial here
is just a recipe
to create some
test probabilities.
That's all it is.
The binomial here
doesn't really matter.
It's really to create
the test probabilities.
And then I'm going to define
this test statistic, which
is known as the chi-square
statistic, right?
This was the chi-square test.
We just looked at sum of the
square root of the differences.
Inverting the covariance matrix
or using the Fisher information
with removing the part
that was not invertible
led us to actually use
this particular value here,
and then we had
to multiply by n.
OK?
And that, we know,
converges to what?
A chi-square distribution.
So I'm not going to
go through this again.
I'm just telling you you
can use the chi-square
that we've seen, where we just
came up with the numbers we
were testing.
Those numbers that were in this
row for the true probabilities,
we came up with them
out of thin air.
And now I'm telling
you you can actually
come up with those guys
from a binomial distribution
or a Poisson
distribution or whatever
distribution you're happy with.
Any question?
So now I'm creating
this thing, and I
can apply the entire theory
that I have for the chi-square
and, in particular, that
this thing converges
to a chi-square.
But if you see, there's
something that's different.
What is different?
The degrees of freedom.
And if you think about it,
again, the meaning of degrees
of freedom.
What does this word--
these words actually mean?
It means, well, to
which extent can I
play around with those values?
What are the possible
values that I can get?
If I'm not equal to this
particular value I'm testing,
how many directions can I
be different from this guy?
And when we had a
given set of values,
we could be any other
set of values, right?
So here, I had this--
I'm going to represent-- this
is the set of all probability
distributions of vectors
of size K. So here,
if I look at one
point in this set,
this is something that looks
like p1 through pK such that
their sum--
such that they're non-negative,
and the sum p1 through pK
is equal to 1.
OK?
So I have all those points here.
So this is basically the
set that I had before.
I was testing whether I
was equal to this one guy,
or if I was anything else.
And there's many ways
I can be anything else.
What matters, of course,
is what's around this guy
that I could actually
confuse myself with.
But there's many ways I
can move around this guy.
Agreed?
Now I'm actually just testing
something very specific.
I'm saying, well,
now the piece that I
have had to come
from this-- have
to be constructed from this
formula, this parametric family
P of theta.
And there's a fixed way for--
let's say this is theta,
so I have a theta here.
There's not that many ways
this can actually give me
a set of probabilities, right?
I have to move to another
theta to actually start
being confused.
And so here the number
of degrees of freedom
is basically, how can I
move along this family?
And so here, this
is all the points,
but there might
be just the subset
of the points that looks
like this, just this curve,
not the half of this thing.
And those guys on this
curve are the p thetas,
and that's for all thetas
when theta runs across data.
So in a way, this is just a
much smaller dimensional thing.
It's a much smaller object.
Those are only the
ones that I can
create that are exactly of this
very specific parametric form.
And of course, not
all are of this form.
Not all probability
PMFs are of this form.
And so that is going
to have an effect
on what my PMF is going to be--
sorry, on what my--
sorry, what my degrees of
freedoms are going to be.
Because when this thing is
very small, that means when--
that's happening when
theta is actually,
say, a one-dimensional
space, then there's still
many ways I can escape, right?
I can be different
from this guy in pretty
much every other direction,
except for those two
directions, just
when I move from here
or when I move in
this direction.
But now if this
thing becomes bigger,
your theta is, say,
two dimensional,
then when I'm here
it's becoming harder
for me to not be that guy.
If I want to move
away from it, then I
have to move away
from the board.
And so that means that
the bigger the dimension
of my theta, the smaller
the degrees of freedoms
that I have, OK, because moving
out of this parametric family
is actually very
difficult for me.
So if you think, for
example, as an extreme case,
the parametric family that I
have is basically all PMFs,
all of them, right?
So that's a stupid
parametric family.
I'm indexed by the
distribution itself,
but it's still
finite dimensional.
Then here, I have basically
no degrees of freedom.
There's no way I
can actually not
be that guy, because this
is everything I have.
And so you don't have
to really understand
how the computation comes
into the numbers of dimension
and what I mean by dimension
of this current space.
But really, what's important is
that as the dimension of theta
becomes bigger, I have
less degrees of freedom
to be away from this family.
This family becomes big,
and it's very hard for me
to violate this.
So it's actually shrinking
the number of degrees
of freedom of my chi-square.
And that's all you
need to understand.
When d increases, the number of
degrees of freedom decreases.
And I'd like to you to have an
idea of why this is somewhat
true, and this is
basically the picture
you should have in mind.
OK.
So now once I have done
this, I can just construct.
So here I need to check.
So what is d in the
case of the binomial?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: 1, right?
It's just a
one-dimensional thing.
And for most of
the examples we're
going to have it's going
to be one dimensional.
So we have this weird thing.
We're going to have K
minus 2 degrees of freedom.
So now I have this thing,
and I have this asymptotic.
And then I can just basically
use a test that has--
that uses the fact that
the asymptotic distribution
is this.
So I compute my
quantiles out of this.
Again, I made the same mistake.
This should be q alpha,
and this should be q alpha.
So that's just the
tail probability
is equal to alpha when I'm
on the right of q alpha.
And so those are
the tail probability
of the appropriate chi-square
with the appropriate number
of degrees of freedom.
And so I can compute p-values,
and I can do whatever I want.
OK?
So then I just like [INAUDIBLE]
my testing machinery.
OK?
So now I know how to test if I'm
a binomial distribution or not.
Again here, testing if I'm
a binomial distribution
is not a simple goodness of fit.
It's a composite one
where I can actually--
there's many ways I can
be a binomial distribution
because there's as
many as there is theta.
And so I'm actually plugging
in the theta hat, which is
estimated from the data, right?
And here, since everything's
happening in the asymptotics,
I'm not claiming that Tn
has a pivotal distribution
for finite n.
That's actually not true.
It's going to depend
like crazy on what
the actual distribution is.
But asymptotically,
I have a chi-square,
which obviously does not
depend on anything [INAUDIBLE]..
OK?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in general, for
the binomial [INAUDIBLE] trials.
But in the general
case, the number of--
the size of our PMF is
the number of [INAUDIBLE]..
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So let's
say that I was also
uncertain about what
K was so that I don't
know how big my [INAUDIBLE] is.
[INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
That is correct.
And thank you for this beautiful
segue into my next slide.
So we can actually
deal with the case
not only where it's
infinite, which
would be the case of Poisson.
I mean, nobody
believes I'm going
to get an infinite
number of photons
in a finite amount of time.
But we just don't want to have
to say there's got to be a--
this is the largest
possible number.
We don't want to
have to do that.
Because if you start doing
this and the probabilities
become close to 0, things become
degenerate and it's an issue.
So what we do is we bin.
We just bin stuff.
OK?
And so maybe if I have
a binomial distribution
with, say, 200,000
possible values,
then it's actually maybe
not the level of precision
I want to look at this.
Maybe I want to bin.
Maybe I want to say,
let's just think
of all things that
are between 0 and 100
to be the same thing, between
100 and 200 the same thing,
et cetera.
And so in fact, I'm
actually going to bin.
I don't even have to think
about things that are discrete.
I can even think about
continuous cases.
And so if I want to test if I
have a Gaussian distribution,
for example, I can just
approximate that by some,
say, piecewise constant
function that just says that,
well, if I have a Gaussian
distribution like this,
I'm going to bin it like this.
And I'm going to say, well,
the probability that I'm
less than this value is this.
The probability that I'm between
this and this value is this.
The probability I'm
between this and this value
is this, and then this
and then this, right?
And now I've turned--
I've discretized, effectively,
my Gaussian into a PMF.
The value-- this is p1.
The value here is p1.
This is p2.
This is p3.
This is p4.
This is p5 and p6, right?
I have discretized my Gaussian
into six possible values.
That's just the probability that
they fall into a certain bin.
And we can do this--
if you don't know what
K is, just stop at 10.
You look at your data quickly
and you say, well, you know,
I have so few of them that are--
like I see maybe one 8, one 11,
and one 15.
Well, everything
that's between 8 and 20
I'm just going to
put it in one bin.
Because what else
are you going to do?
I mean, you just don't
have enough observations.
And so what we do is
we just bin everything.
So here I'm going to actually
be slightly abstract.
Our bins are going
to be intervals Aj.
So here-- they don't even
have to be intervals.
I could go crazy and just
like call the bin this guy
and this guy, right?
That would make no sense,
but I could do that.
And then I'm-- and of course,
you can do whatever you want,
but there's going to be some
consequences in the conclusions
that you can take, right?
All you're going
to be able to say
is that my distribution
does not look like it
could be binned in this way.
That's all you're going
to be able to say.
So if you decide to just
put all the negative numbers
and the positive
numbers, then it's
going to be very hard
for you to distinguish
a Gaussian from a random
variable that takes values
of minus 1 and plus 1 only.
You need to just be reasonable.
OK?
So now I have my pj's
become the probability
that my random variable
falls into bin j.
So that's pj of theta under
the parametric distribution.
For the true one, whether it's
parametric or not, I have a pj.
And then I have
p hat j, which is
the proportion of observations
that falls in this bin.
All right?
So I have a bunch
of observations.
I count how many of
them fall in this bin.
I divide by n, and that
tells me what my estimated
probability for this bin is.
And theta hat, well,
it's the same as before.
If I'm in a
parametric family, I'm
just estimating theta hat,
maybe the maximum likelihood
estimator, plug it
in, and estimate
those pj's of theta hat.
From this, I form my
chi-square, and I have exactly
the same thing as before.
So the answer to your
question is, yes, you bin.
And it's the answer to
even more questions.
So that's why there
you can actually
use the chi-square test
to test for normality.
Now here it's going
to be slightly weaker,
because there's only
an asymptotic theory,
whereas Kolmogorov-Smirnov
and Kolmogorov-Lilliefors work
actually even for
finite samples.
For the chi-square test,
it's only asymptotic.
So you just pretend you actually
know what the parameters are.
You just stuff them
into a theta, a mu hat,
and sigma square hat.
And you just go to-- you
just cross your finger
that n is large
enough for everything
to have converged by the
time you make your decision.
OK?
And then this is a copy/paste,
with the same error actually
as the previous slide, where
you just build your test based
on whether you exceed
or not some quantile,
and you can also
compute some p-value.
OK?
AUDIENCE: The error?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: What's the error?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
What is the error?
AUDIENCE: You said [INAUDIBLE]
copy/paste [INAUDIBLE]..
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Oh,
the error is that this
should be q alpha, right?
AUDIENCE: OK.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: I've
been calling this q alpha.
I mean, that's my
personal choice,
because I don't want to--
I only use q alpha.
So I only use quantiles where
alpha is to the right, so.
That's what statisticians--
probabilists
would use this notation.
OK.
And so some questions, right?
So of course, in
practice you're going
to have some issues
which translate.
I say, well, how do you
pick this guy, this K?
So I gave you some sort of a--
I mean, the way we
discussed, right?
You have 8 and 10 and
20, then it's ad hoc.
And so depending on whether
you want to stop K at 20
or if you want to bin those
guys is really up to you.
And there's going to
be some considerations
about the particular
problem at hand.
I mean, is it
coarse-- too coarse
for your problem to decide
that the observations between 8
and 20 are the same?
It's really up to you.
Maybe that's actually
making a huge difference
in terms of what phenomenon
you're looking at.
The choice of the bins, right?
So here there's
actually some sort
of rules, which are
don't use only one bin
and make sure there's actually--
don't use them too small
so that there's at least one
observation per bin, right?
And it's basically
the same kind of rules
that you would have
to build a histogram.
If you were to build a
histogram for your data,
you still want to
make sure that you
bin in an appropriate fashion.
OK?
And there's a bunch
of rule of thumbs.
Every time you ask
someone, they're
going to have a
different rule of thumb,
so just make your own.
And then there's the
computation of pj
of theta, which might
be a bit complicated
because, in this
case, I would have
to integrate the Gaussian
between this number
and this number.
So for this case, I
could just say, well,
it's the difference of the CDF
in that value and that value
and then be happy with it.
But you can imagine that
you have some slightly more
crazy distributions.
You're going to have
to somewhat compute
some integrals that might be
unpleasant for you to compute.
OK?
And in particular, I
said the difference
of the PDF between that value
and that value of-- sorry,
the CDF between that value
and that value, it is true.
But it's not like
you actually have
tables that compute the CDF
at any value you like, right?
You have to sort of--
well, there might be
but at some degree,
but you are going to have
to use a computer typically
to do that.
OK?
And so for example, you
could do the Poisson.
If I had time, if I had
more than one minute,
I would actually do it for you.
But it's basically the same.
The Poisson, you are going
to have an infinite tail,
and you just say,
at some point I'm
going to cut everything
that's larger than some value.
All right?
So you can play around, right?
I say, well, if you have extra
knowledge about what you expect
to see, maybe you can
cut at a certain number
and then just fold all the
largest values from K minus 1
to infinity so that
you actually have--
you have everything
into one large bin.
OK?
That's the entire tail.
And that's the way people do
it in insurance companies,
for example.
They assume that the number of
accidents you're going to have
is a Poisson distribution.
They have to fit it to you.
They have to know--
or at least to your pool of
insurance of injured people.
So they just slice you
into what your character--
relevant characteristics
are, and then they
want to estimate what the
Poisson distribution is.
And basically, they can
do a chi-square test
to check if it's indeed
a Poisson distribution.
All right.
So that will be it for today.
And so I'll be--
I'll have your homework--